كان هناك شيء على قدم وساق في محاكمة مجلس الشيوخ لعزل مجلس الشيوخ
وهو محامي الرئيس
جادل في قضيته. أود منك أن
تضع حذائك بنفسك في
حذاء الرئيس ، فلا عجب أنه تعرض
للتعثر بسبب الأحذية لم يستطع جاي سيكولو التوقف عن
ذكرها ضع نفسك
في حذائه ، هل تضعون أنفسكم في مكان
ليس فقط رئيس أي
رئيس تضع نفسك في حذائه
إشارة إلى أن حذاء المهرج ضع نفسك في
حذاء الرئيس في الواقع ،
كان الديمقراطيون هم من وضعوا أفضل ما لديهم في
البداية.  لقول أنك
لا تفهم شخصًا ما حتى تخطو
في حذائه بعد أيام ، اقتبس سيركولو من
شيف لكنه تمكن من وضع قدمه في
فمه مع كل إشاراته إلى
الأحذية مرة أخرى ، ضع حذائك في مكانه وضع
قدميك في حذاء الرئيس
ضع نفسك في موقف الرئيس الذي
لم يستطع النقاد مقاومة السخرية من السير
في حذاء ترامب ، لقد فعلت ذلك
وخلصت إلى أنه يجب علي الاستقالة على
الفور وهناك في الواقع
ورق تواليت  k في حذائي
قد لا يكون مؤهلًا كجريمة عالية ، فإنه
يصنف بالتأكيد على أنه جنحة مشط القدم
جين موس سي إن إن نيويورك